I have been training myself to breathe
exclusively through my nose for almost a
year
now you know that's actually like it's
like a big deal yeah apparently yeah
that's why I started that pit poor poor
mouth posture and and shitty habits have
led a lot of people to be very mouth
breathy but Mouth breathing weakens your
air passages and there like it leads to
more like sleep apnea issues and like it
it makes it makes you less healthy in
general because it makes your breathing
worse yeah apparently just like I didn't
know this I learned this a week ago oh
yeah and I was like oh [__] I breathe
through my mouth all the time man I
should have been talking about this a
while ago then because yeah I started on
the adventure like yeah about N9 months
ago or something like that or eight
months ago right
uh oh yeah game hello happy Halloween
this
year I got this available through the
link in the description below the last
YouTubes that will ever be mine that
I'll do the last YouTub I'll ever this
is my final
goodbye I'm not quitting or anything
this is just the last oh boy here's dark
applier with uh special you can't really
see inside very well but it's
uh
that you know you'd think that I would
pitch this better think that I would
have set up the blue lighting back there
too so it' be the red
and available now for a limited time
darkiplier you's I'm not going to open
it then it wouldn't be Mint
Condition you can see what it is it's a
little dark in there get it it's a
little dark in
there any hey everyone welcome to CX
it's not a stream wait you don't have
to hey guys welcome to CX with Mark and
Bob or Mark and my hey guys guys welcome
tox why did Mark disconnect I didn't
disconnect did I you disappeared on our
oh why did day let me back
in oh so I've played this once I don't
remember the controls I didn't host so
hopefully it'll still give us tutorial
guidance otherwise we're kind of screwed
but this is a game where we build
Furniture together as a team like IKEA
style right yeah but worse let's
why are we in space you mean cooler what
am I what is this diagram of yeah what
am I that is our map we will be playing
on okay good is it we assemble furniture
and put it on that assembly line when
it's done and that's how we get credit
for it it's kind of like um the
different cooking games like when you
finish a meal and you put it
on ah I'm those hey here we go pick
whack together got it that's pretty easy
I'm
ready I'm ready three two one go I
already have a bad feeling about this
I'm the chair I'm the butt I'm the butt
but got it got
it hurry up waade what the how did I
hurry up got it how am I holding it now
I thought did I steal this from you oh
yeah no you you knocked it out of my
hands by
dashing me on the Belt oh
no don't put me on the Bel sorry stop uh
[__] you did how do you what are you
even doing I got him I got him
Bob got him are we not working together
as a team on this or we are I think that
was just showing us the first two
controls pick up and throw there's
more all right excellent these do get
timed later so like that one wasn't but
they was hting rotate smack it together
oh you have to put the dowels in oh dear
me goodness
oh spicy I have a famous quote that you
may have heard Ryan play for you on
stream let me put my [__] wiener in
you dog wieners Y no I know it I know
about your weth of dog wieners dog
wiener put your wiener in put your
wiener in me put your wiener in me put
your wiener in me wait can you put a
wiener in yourself oh you can put a Wier
in yourself you go wait oh oh it's x x
is to like confirm it in there okay uh
uh oh well this is hardly difficult oh
the lag makes it more
interesting I got him I got him W so why
wait can you not get out if I do this
stop no what am I supposed to do about
that I can't do anything oh no wait
please you can't do anything oh you can
do spam B spam B to a free
yourself I it's stop sit still what
I was really trying Bob I was hey wait a
minute you see the spam B thing yeah I
do hey oh I did it wow well that was
hardly fun nail gun you're hardly fun
hey wait why number one number one
that's some bll I dowed so many sticks I
I saw you wiered everything I shake it
like the best of them what does that
even mean so now we have different
patterns and things to look at oh [__]
that means
mean okay don't worry I'll be the smart
one all right uh four wieners four legs
put them on the thing the we need a
specific seat it needs to be the flower
this is not the right seat we're missing
something that was right just rotate the
table man this isn't the right seat
that's not the right legs okay oh okay
we seem to be missing a
sausage so it's flower up oh no I weed
both ends I wiered both
ends I think the line the the line of
the leg needs to be closest to the table
so the opposite of that uhuh that's just
what they want you to think that's not
right here come look at the diagram guys
I don't need to look I'm confused wait
I'm confused look at the diagram
oh oh I see okay you could put the leg
on either which way yes oh I got it you
got like this so mark your leg is your
wiener is the wrong hole you have to
Wier the correct leg Mark no no no what
if I just put the wieners in there that
makes more sense and then usually
whenever I we this before we wiered the
table God stop getting in the grab Zone
where's the oh my bad I was trying to
wiener our wieners are gone yeah where
are
they
Wier oh thanks what the fre man sorry
where' the wieners go no that's not
right me no hold
on where are they don't take I was I I
need it there we go I fixed it Mark
don't worry uh-huh all right well who's
hiding a wiener it's on the wrong side
flip the table over oh no is there a
wiener on the other side oh no we got to
get rid of
it damn it we go oh you know what I'm
starting to see how this might be
difficult way I've got to be honest no
no what did you do
way that's the right side isn't it no
it's not no it's not I thought the
flower the legs go on the pointy side
not the rounded side oh I didn't see
that I was looking at the flower being
with the weener side so
that no not that one God oh no it's
fine easy whoa I'm the greatest I'm the
greatest I'm the greatest no I'm oh no
it was
wrong what did we do wrong oh you know
what guys the legs go on the routed side
not the pointy
side man I was so confidently wrong why
did you all to listen to me you're idiot
you said so strongly the idiot the
directions I think changed right what no
I no but the legs now the the line side
is up now huh see line side is up it's
got to go no line is changed I'm telling
you it changed oh well there it goes the
legs oh the leg orientation is what
you're talking about I I see I see yeah
no you're right the line side is up
could not be more right I just
accidentally wiered correctly I'm the
luckiest man alive godamn it can we why
is stop why is the table in the air I'm
trying not to we're all working to the
same thing oh man I put the line down
why is there a leg on a non- weener hole
I look can someone can someone get that
leg off the we just we'll just start
over no no we'll just start over it's
fine I'm on leg Duty flower side up the
rounded flower with weing I'm weing On
Top yes yes I'm legging yes yes yes yes
harder this wait wait
wait moving I'm not moving I'm not
moving okay oh man it's fine it's fine
we're F that was so much harder we got
six we got $16 for that it's another one
is that oh [__] it's not done okay FL
star side has legs and line down okay so
like
this yes when you say line down do you
mean line line towards the table okay
got
it what happened wait the table's upside
down okay it's okay I fixed it right
okay easy peasy well there's an art to
this h a you did a not throw it what do
you mean
Oh I thought you threw it I was doing
that during the first round the entire
time that's why I couldn't finish any
I'm number one I got minus 48 guys
that's my bad you want to retry it for
Max stars or move on
I got Max stars in my heart is it even
building Furniture if you don't do it
wrong at least a couple times all right
wow look at all the places I got
disconnected again sity swaity help help
help oh Mark Mark disconnected that's
what he said help oh hey there he is
yeah okay L1 means you can remove stuff
you can flip things you can flip
it that would be very I thought you guys
knew that well
it's saying that you could flip it while
it's like attached or something maybe I
don't know I'm confused oh sweet Jesus
oh God where are you going don't worry
guys I'll do what is this flower side up
lines
up okay okay uh I'm bringing legs I'm
just going to bring legs over yeah we
need to bring it through here first cuz
how do I drop something how do I drop
something uh right right trigger is
throw oh boy
I think we bring all the pieces into
this room was it wait was it was it
rounded side up or Point rounded up and
then the lines pointed up there's a
small
table uh we got multiple things to do
we're on a timer well timer schimer
rotate it with a left bumper I'm
trying uh flower side up so round it up
oh oh man I wish there was a way to set
things down that was not that yeah is
there not all right if you if you pick
if you pick something else up you can
you can set something down and then pick
the other thing
up
Mark Mark what what lines up right Wade
yeah yeah like the ones that are on
there hey I made
money wait where's the last wiener uh
yeah we're missing a ween somewhere
wiener I don't see a
wi oh um hello over here no oh we oh
sorry
sorry why I said sorry uh
sorry he said sorry H you're right
you're right and now we have a minute to
do it again star side up lines down a
minute or or what happens I'm bringing
I'm bringing the leg the line legs over
to the main room okay I'm doing the
small one
no okay they can fall into space Oh
biscuits hey what happens if I threw
away a leg uh it should pop back
somewhere one of the rooms that's fine
probably oh
oops small one
done all
right bringing the lag
in oh I forgot about boost I got the
waiter okay
dance is there like a dance I can
do we did it
oh wait what wait flow flower up line
down cury or pointy pointy or cury cury
or pointy oh
God oh God guys we were so
close we get we got 192 we needed 212 to
get for the third star why is wave
number one he didn't even get a point I
know look at how many points I got this
is
ridiculous don't actually go ahead laugh
like that see if I care I didn't give
you permission to laugh like that I do
care all right guys we have put together
a TV table okay all right oh no it's a
lamp oh God lamp
do you need instructions oh my God is
there in instructions or something yeah
on the wall see on the wall here it's
it's nubbin for every tube connector
there's a tube with a nubbin in the
middle that nubbin into the D knock the
can you knock the wean over so I can
wean it I need a bulb you see a light
bulb if I here if I rotate and hold it
does that help you
guys okay here and then yeah that goes
in this nubbin here where's the light
bulb right there oh I don't know oh it's
in the corner top right corner uhhuh
yeah so yeah wait yeah there you go and
then you Dome Dome that into the nubbin
on the side here put it in Wade I'm
trying you're I'm literally not in your
way at all on my screen I don't know
what to tell you all right it's done
right yeah yeah under oh got to do again
okay well that's why aren't you helping
I'm you I will help you here I'll hold
I'll hold the platform wean me all right
we me and trap me not that one okay
weaning there's already a we oh wait oh
wait a minute yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah what is happening where did that go
I need it here we go I got it what is
happening where did [__] did the other
piece go here we go won Mark's on it I
panicked and threw it I'm sorry it's
over here wait stick it on stick it on
stick it on stick it oh no we have too
many wieners what do you mean wait stick
it stick it on stick it
on we it oh my God stick it onck St
moving stick it on just hit squ here we
go go go go go go no for
God you didn't just you just didn't you
didn't you just didn't Wade okay all
right to Wade's defense I double clicked
the attach button on that last lamp
piece it didn't ATT wiener needed to
wiener the whole was on the
ground well we tried moving on to the
next one it that was pretty good that
was pretty good I think I'm going to get
what um come here don't fight this oh
hey hey come here come here don't I
trust you implicitly wait come here come
your way come your way come here come
here I don't like this there you go you
could aim you I'm not fighting you I
don't get why you're in such a hurry oh
cool we're here
now what's up here throw me over there
yeah here uh y okay oh the instruction
are the same me the thing wait no the
instructions are the same so I can't
really oh I can hop across okay wait oh
yeah there's a jump button wait a minute
oh no oh do this need to be painted what
are you doing I don't know
that hey
wait wait no the table
okay
uh uh what are the instructions uh say
uh oh yeah that's I don't know oh God I
keep it doesn't say which side needs to
go up H
whatever what how did you I don't know
oh I just what are you're so stupid how
any any indication oh it's on the ground
it's on the ground in the other area
hello what do you mean come here you
didn't get it either come here hello
hello okay I'm a willing participant I'm
so willing damn it you could aim just
Mark I don't know what to tell you oh
you have I think you have to go from
this side then go over there
oh I'll save
you
what if I throw behind me oh oops
sorry all
right boy to redo this I don't think we
passed we did we passed look Wade's
number one we I saw you as number one
Mark oh that's so sweet I'm going to be
I'm going to be in charge of this I've
got it I've got the solution all right
waade throw me over here can't you dash
across that Mark isn't that way you no
you can Dash back from it so I'll wait
here for the instructions once you get
the instructions I'll let you know which
it is wait I'm
disconnecting wait instructions he
Mark's the one on them I'm
disconnecting yeah you seem to have
disconnected Mark I don't know why
probably cuz you suck no got him got him
I mean you might be right no look I have
10 gigabit internet oh a lot of
good
look if it comes with a few hiccups it's
so worth it y me okay well y me one of
Direction one you need to put the table
together uh okay well this is simple
what is it it's just the round table
right it'll yeah it'll get there as soon
as this uh other one is
ready I I have a lamp the next one will
be a lamp okay here we go all right I'm
throwing it whoops got it okay it's fine
it's fine uh table do you have a table
yep table uh star Side Up leg line legs
toward the table star side up with no
legs star side has legs pointy side has
legs go towards table okay got it star
up line down no no no no no I haven't
made line down line down line of the leg
closest to the table I believe yes okay
so star side up that's the side you put
the legs on line of the leg closest to
the table start up line down what I
think that's very [__] simple you
think it's clear it's
not star side up where's we're missing a
nubbing oh might be it's under the table
on the wrong side oh no
no God damn it uh see the table go
flying Mark wait hang on hey wait can
you toss
me I'm assuming they're different hey
Mark can
you hey wa can you toss me over to the
instruction Mark I just have a feeling
this is right so I'm going to go with my
gut I'm ready you're almost definitely
correct yep we don't have time toss it
toss It Go Get It Go Get it get it get
it it was wrong damn it well we tried
our best just going to put this okay all
right no I think probably I should have
gone and looked at the new instructions
no hey Mark you're number one of that
I'm number one baby we're going back why
do we have to go back we haven't passed
what do you mean we passed F okay we
passed fine man this is going so
well you know wait I I have a common
denominator here is that Bob's not on
this side Bob were you not there to
catch it God damn it oh my
God about that common denominator thing
I you didn't say I needed to actively
catch it I assumed you just Huck it
across why would you throw yourself into
the void here it comes here it comes Bor
throw me oh no I can't okay thank you
you all right uh okay it is okay leg
side is receiving on the flowers it is
it is the line away from the flowers
what leg side is receiving on the
flower lying away from the
flower
[__] I can't make C line up line away
from the flower leg side receiving on
the flowers is line away from the
flowers flower up line up got
it leg side is on the flowers cuz if you
say flower up that makes me think when
the table is back right side up the
flower would be
up what leg are receiving on the
flowers what is confusing about
that Bob it's coming okay I'm ready all
right I hope that's right all right good
job oh no lamp whatever you did it we
did it what are you worried about leg
side ising on the flowers bulb side
reing on the lamp bulge the lip balls
receiving B just turn that in I fell
off I thought I thought the first thing
was what you were throwing to me but it
was just fell into the abyss the leg
side is receiving on the
flowers the leg side is receiving on the
flowers look he doesn't need any other
words because those are the perfect
words to describe it are the perfect
words
OB look when you guys God you guys have
your complex instructions mine are so
clear cuz you understand them shape you
see flower okay line down close to the
table up away no because you you are not
accounting for full threedimensional
potential no I'm a for what we [__]
see in the heat of a goddamn Speed
Build I'm not oh the lers are sitting on
the flowers but only on the spring of
May I I I will give you the clear
instructions all right oh Mark is the
only one allowed to read instructions
from here on
out oh no new new rule new rule hey oh
my God it takes three of us oh [__] no
probably not it looks like it does l
side is receiving of the flowers let me
just [__] okay all right jees okay so
you've got uh checkerboard pattern is on
the distal
edges
uh nope that is so clear here I what
distal mean longboard in between distal
what do you distance oh okay got it got
it checkerboard pattern on the distal
edges tessellation interior so that's
the top so how do we we go like nope we
go like that nope wait I think you need
to rotate
yours yeah checkerboard distal it's
literally yeah checkerboard pattern on
the distal
edges interior board is shorter holy
moving Mar SC screw is this right check
inside well wait no distal distal there
we go whoa okay it's the the shorter
board the shorter board is on the
interior oh I don't know what that means
shorter board is in between shorter
board is attached to the tesselated
edges the checkerboard patterns is
distal where's the gun um what is
happening I like this yes exactly L like
that except you can't access the hole
you need to wait turn your
[__] yes yes no turn it slightly less
more there mark wait please for the love
of God no other way no what no dist
there yes yes yes yes
yes what that means why am I holding
this the tricker patterns on the distal
edges uh-huh keep saying that it's and
then that goes on the top I'm trying
Wade seems to have dropped the the thing
for no apparent
reason hey Mark yeah what's up I got I
got I got I got Bam Bam okay go bam done
done done
teleporter T press the button what
button teleport me hey the Buton I'm
trying it's not I'm a oh it needs power
it needs a power thing oh it's gone it's
gone oh my god oh hey there we go that
was really this Edge is on the left side
of the upper CL it is the
distal part of it Mark if we don't know
what distal means then it doesn't matter
how much you explain that it's the
distal Edge I got to be honest no no
it's
distal I said distal not not
Crystal not fistol dist no no it's
distal it's pronounced
distal distl is an adjective think we
learn it is a descriptor for the the
ends the end the ends of
what